um we'll make a start
welcome to this meeting of the labor
planning committee I will now ask the
governance officer to read out the
domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations Claire thank you
chat please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you're attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phone's on
silent or switched off and that your
laptop is also switched to silent you'll
be using the e-voting for this meeting
on the modgov app so please commend us
make sure they are logged in and ready
to use the app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to consented to be recorded by entering
the meeting as a speaker you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council under the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the fire alarm please leave
the building immediately via fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
which is Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the science directing this fire
exit the ends of each floor
do not re-enter the building until sold
is safe to do so thank you chair
thank you Claire introductions this
morning area planning manager Mark
Russell is with us our legal advisor Ian
Dupree
case officers Samantha Summers and
Elizabeth flood and our governance
officer Claire Philpot you've already
met
can I move to the agenda please thank
you do you have any apologies for
absence and
no substitutions in that case
are there any Declarations of interest
from anyone
okay
moving on confirmation of the minutes
held on the 22nd of February you've also
had a copy by now are there any points
regarding the accuracy
of these minutes
if not because I have a proposal for the
minutes please councilor Osborne Council
James into sevens
interesting
we're going to do electronic though
clown and over to you
thank you members that is now in
progress councilor beer four thank you
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous thank you
thank you very much
notice your petitions
site inspections any requests
no thank you
we'll move on to schedule of planning
applications we have
um
a comment here on PL 2229 from the area
planning manager
thank you chair this is already covered
in the tabled papers I just wanted to
remind members that the uh since
publication of the agenda The Joint
local plan has has advanced
on the 16th of March the modifications
for part one were published and it's now
out to consultation so these policies
now have added weight before they were
limited weight now they have added
weight they're still not part of the
development plan but they are
progressing I see shakings a bit
just that in some cases added weight is
not a benefit limiting weight is better
thank you gentlemen
thank you
thank you Mark
right
we will move on to
dc2101 802 lands south of honeysuckle
Cottage little Orchard Holbrook
can I just confirm councilman McLaren
that she's going to speak as a ward
member rather than stay in the committee
yes thank you Chad
thank you
I would invite the case officer Samantha
Summers to introduce the application to
the committee Sam all yours
Thank You Cher
for self-build detached dwellings and
includes the access point and full
planning permission for four two-bedroom
dwellings with Landscaping vehicular and
pedestrian accesses
the application comes to committee as it
is considered to be controversial
Parish Council
the ward member and 48 households
objected to the scheme and four
households supported the application
the application site is land south of
honeysuckle Cottage little Orchard in
Holbrook
Holbrook is classed as a core Village in
the core strategy core Villages act as
the focus for development within their
functional clusters because of the level
of services and amenities they provide
to residents
the site sits behind existing dwellings
on Church Hill and the fire station that
is located on the corner of Church Hill
and higham's Lane
this is the village of Holbrook and the
built up area boundary is shown with the
orange line
science sits in the southern part of the
village and is shown in pink
the site sits outside of the built-up
area boundary
this aerial photograph shows the site in
pink in context to its surroundings
most of the built form of the village is
located to the north of the site
the site wraps around the fire station
on two sides
there is open Countryside to the south
and west of the site
inspection on the 27th of October 2021
this plan shows the location of services
within the village in context to where
the site is located
there are bus stops
um
along Ipswich Road and Churchill
the high school is located up here
Primary School just here
we have the Village Hall
the co-op store and the doctors surgery
and children's play area all in this
area here
All Saints Church is directly opposite
you're well located to access these
facilities by foot along made up
footpaths
this plan shows the constraints of the
site the main constraint is the Suffolk
coast and heaths area of outstanding
natural beauty which is shown with the
green area to the south of the site the
grade 2 style listed All Saints Church
sits to the east of the site
the green circles that you might be able
to see in this area here and just here
are protected trees there are none on
the site itself
this is the proposed site layout the
poor self-build units are in outline and
therefore we do not have details of the
exact layout design scale or Landscaping
at this time
they're located in this Northern area of
the site
the details of those units would come
forward as a reserve matters application
self builds are located in the northern
section of the site the four
two-bedroomed units would be located in
the southern section
the access to the site would be from
higham's Lane to the South
this would utilize an existing informal
access to the site that has become
overgrown over time
there's an existing pond on the site
which is to be retained close to the
site entrance
bike area for storing Cycles would be
located at the entrance to the site
eight Cycles would be provided for in
that area
there are four dwellings with private
Gardens
those parking spaces uh
two parking spaces provided for each
dwelling along here
volunteer and also two visitors parking
Bays so a total of 10 parking spaces
for this full planning part of the
scheme
the dwellings have been located outside
of the sewage treatment plant odor Zone
which
it's not very clear on this plan but is
shown with a blue line
just cutting across the site
uh
the H boundary
would be communally managed outside of
the residence Gardens which would be
divided by a poster and rail fence
pedestrian access would be provided
between wheel rights Cottage and Jubilee
House
following the demolition of the garage
to Jubilee House
so just in this section here and would
pop out onto Church Hill
pedestrian access points although
higham's Lane is very narrow and has
been subject to many concerns raised by
the objectors
the design of the proposed two-bedroom
dwellings is contemporary and would be
in the form of a Terrace
the dwellings would be finished in clay
hanging tiles vertical Timber boarding
red brick clay plain tile roof and
recessed PV solar panels to the roof
this drawing shows the heights of the
dwellings in comparison with other
structures nearby
we have the church
over here
we have the fire station training Tower
just
volunteer and then to the left of that
plan we have some existing houses
this is shown from the Western Viewpoint
uh with the land falling away to the
South
these are the floor plans and the roof
plans of the two bedroomed units
this shows the proposed development site
um and how it would sit with the
existing
built form around the site so the site
is just here
although this is a superseded plan the
drawing has slight slightly changed
through the course of the application
this just gives you an indication of how
the site would sit with its buildings
and just showing the context with the
existing buildings around the site
this plan shows the proposed access
point uh to the site and you can see the
Contemporary nature of the buildings
just here and the planting that would be
put in place
this plan shows the vehicular access
onto Heinz Lane with the visibility
displays shown in pink or within the
highway Verge area
of outstanding natural beauty but is
adjacent to it
the comments of the aom officer have
been addressed on widening on the
widening of heims Lane the lane is to be
retained in its current form
some maintenance will be required to the
existing Hedgerow for cutting back to
make sure that we have the necessary
visibility displays
the development is not considered to be
harmful to the setting of The aomb
some trees are to be removed from the
site however further planting is
proposed to offset any loss of the trees
on the site
the site is well screened from wider
landscape views
this shows the planting and landscaping
around the access point and shows the
visibility displays and the planting set
back from those visibility displays
uh again this plan just shows uh that
planting that is proposed outside of the
visibility displays to help to screen
the site from the area of outstanding
natural beauty
moving on to some photographs of the
site and the surroundings this
photograph is taken from the proposed
access with the fire station drill Tower
you can just see that on the left hand
side of the photograph
the row of uh Terraces would be located
here
with that existing Hedgerow screening it
from The Wider landscape views
this is taken looking
uh
took along uh South sorry get my words
out South and looking at that existing
Hedgerow
this is looking towards that fire
station drill Tower
uh this is looking back from the site to
the access point onto Heinz Lane
this one is looking from the access
point a long Hymes laying back towards
Church Hill you have the fire station
actually on the left hand side of that
photograph
this is the location of the proposed
pedestrian access onto Church Hill
and this is looking from the same point
but in the opposite direction down the
hill towards where higham's Lane
Junction is and which is
beyond that car
this application has been received
following the refusal of a previous
scheme in 2020
DC 2001474
that was also for a hybrid scheme of
outline planning for four self-build
units
and for full planning permission for
five dwellings
all of them being two bedroom dwellings
with vehicular access or poems Lane and
The Pedestrian access to Churchill the
application was refused for three
reasons
Works were required for the access
and it would be detrimental to the rural
character of higham's Lane
the impact on the setting of The aomb
and also there was no unilateral
agreement to find a traffic regulation
order to move the speed limit sign
the revised scheme has addressed those
reasons for refusal with no objections
from the aomb team or from highways
the application has been assessed under
policy cs11 of the core strategy the
application submission did not include a
suitable local housing needs assessment
and has they bought not provided the
required evidence for a need for the
housing
the application was submitted the
hallbrook neighborhood plan has been to
examination
and it is now an advanced stage
therefore the policies are given great
weight the neighborhood plan specifies
that all new Housing Development should
be contained within the settlement
boundary
the application provides four smaller
two-bed units which the neighborhood to
plant has identified a need for in the
village
however
it fails to Target a specific identified
need for one bed homes and for bungalows
furthermore
the council has sufficient planning
permissions relating to self-build units
in Beaver
all of the dwellings are Market housing
and are not affordable which the
neighborhood plan has actually
identified as a need
site and proposal does not reach the
thresholds to provide affordable housing
on this particular scheme because it's
less than 10 dwellings and under 0.5
hectares
the neighborhood plan
uh no sorry
I would draw your attention to
paragraphs 3.11 and 3.18 in your reports
which does detail the need aspect for
the housing
considered to not meet the needs of the
Village
um Holbrook has already reached his
numbers for new dwellings
another change in policy is the way that
the joint local plan is accredited
plan is at public consultation and is
therefore given added weight in decision
making
policy sp03 is sustainable location of
new development
development is required to be within the
settlement boundary unless the site is
allocated for development or is
identified in a neighborhood plan the
application is identified as neither of
these
therefore the application is recommended
for refusal as it is contrary to policy
cs11 policies contained within the
neighborhood plan and also the jlp thank
you
thank you Sam
are there any questions for the officer
councilman Busby I saw you first
it actually hasn't got a number keep
going
concerns me with this is that we know
it's I mean that flattens the slope it
is quite a steep slope isn't it the
access to the site and we know that the
pond is on the left hand side as we look
at it
it looks to me as though
um any water that fall any rain that
falls onto the road or path is going to
come streaming down because this that
part slopes also
left to right
even though that would appear to be
contrary to the way that the road goes
is that an optical illusion am I
no you're quite right the site is
actually on a hillside so
um yes the land Falls away to higham's
Lane if members are minded to approve
the scheme we would require a condition
for surface water drainage details to
ensure that no water is flooding out
onto hims Lane
a beer
thank you Mr chairman could you put up
slowly 25 which I think was your last
one and the officer you did
um sort of refer to 311 and 318 but what
I want to ask you
um it says files to address and what is
specifically a local identified need
what is the Pacific local identified
need
so the local identified need wasn't
addressed as part of the application
submission normally we would receive a
local housing needs
however because the neighborhood plan
actually has that contained within it
we've used and referenced that as our
need because the village have already
identified what the
so one bedroom units smaller units units
for older people so this scheme doesn't
actually provide any Bungalows for
example
um so yes in some parts it has actually
addressed the two bedroom units but the
mix
well there isn't MX it's all just two
bedroom units so we
walked the parish would have liked to
have seen I'm sure is something with one
bedroom units something for older people
so maybe a bungalow or two but because
it's all just one type of mix
so can I
come back on that Mr chairman so what
you're actually saying then that that we
haven't done a housing need there's not
been one presented other than using the
local
um neighborhood plan which comments on
local need
yes is that sufficient then it is yeah
it comes to be sorry that the acomp
studies that were done to uh Acom AECOM
studies which were done to inform the
Holbrook neighborhood plan that's the
technical document that we
yeah
okay sorry I I couldn't see your hand
behind cancel
just I I you know I was worried so the
local neighborhood plan
hasn't been adopted
at the moment so it just sits there
so
what weight are we required to give to a
document that hasn't been adopted
because in my view it's it's still
obviously in The Ether it's not a it's
not an adopted policy position and we
seem to be placing quite a lot of weight
on something that hasn't been adopted
so are we um
put it I I think this is an issue that
we need to do because if it's not
adopted clearly it's not adopted and we
wouldn't use a plan that's not adopted
when it's adopted then it becomes in
place and then we have something to work
with that until such times that that is
adopted would I be right in thinking
that we should just note it
um and uh because I can't we should be
getting a double standard on what is
okay let's get you let's get you an
answer we'll catch you can I just start
up with with because yes
I've got no good plans now at referendum
stage
the examiner's report came out a couple
weeks ago so it's given quite a bit of
weight significant weight not not full
weight because it's not part of the
development plan yet it could feasibly
fail at referendum
experiences by one example that doesn't
happen
and the likelihood is when it gets to
referendum it's likely that it will be
supported so we have to sort of consider
sensibly what the likely outcome is so
we
significant weight and the direction of
travel would suggest that it's going to
be made at some point later this year so
in this case we give it significant
weight
the difference with the jlp is it's at
an earlier consultation stage so that's
got less weight than this has
thank you please I agree totally I can't
it's not yet as we always say as members
are well aware the development plan
under the legislation is the starting
point for your decision the neighborhood
plan is being not yet adopted isn't part
of
the development plan however as Mark
says given the advanced state of the
neighborhood planets and material
consideration that Mark is quite rightly
advising you should have significant
weight
thank you councilorities you want to
come back yeah just so also and the um
we also brought in the uh joint local
plan
[Music]
as Mark mentioned has now gone to
another stage but again it has not been
adopted it is not policy
yes it's in the mix I just feel there's
rather a lot of possibles that we're
looking at here which are not actually
policies that we can hang our hats on
it's slightly confusing
I wish we had a clearer idea so we're
asked to put weight
can I just get my question in Please Mr
chairman um you know we were being asked
to put our decisions based on possible
future adoption of policy I don't think
that's particularly acceptable when we
asked twice to do it I mean once
possibly and I think neighborhood plans
we all agree you know they are the local
issues and the local position
in this instance I would Place
considerable weight on the neighborhood
plan
um and somewhat less weight on the jlp
thank you
sorry
carrying on with this team if I may so
how much weight do we give to our
current local plan
and also the officer mentioned in the
presentation that holbrook's housing
numbers have been met I believe
where is this data drawn from are we
looking at the emerging joint local plan
which does have housing numbers for
specific core Villages or are referring
to other information and data that's
relevant to our current local claim are
we just referring to data from the
neighborhood plan it's confusing to say
the least but how much weight does our
current local plan have and where do
those housing numbers come from so the
housing number for 58 comes from the
consultation draft for the jlp so that's
the work that both in Suffolk has done
and Holbrook is using that as as
Benchmark to say that's what our need is
so those numbers come from the new joint
local plan
yes not from the current local plan not
from the current local plan new joint
local plan has got some weight but not
much weight but we're using the data in
there specifically on this case
as evidence to say they've met the
housing need what you find is that um
it's confusing yeah I know it completely
is I know what you do find is that the
the plan itself whilst it may be delayed
and carry less weight that the documents
back it up quite often carry more weight
so this but being done research done
into the the housing numbers and the
figure that came up for whole book was
58 as opposed to the 69 that been
delivered so therefore there's a surface
there
the jlp itself as a whole document
carries
a bit more now than limited weight it
carries less weight
yeah
the question is that as I say
specifically the officer mentioned a
number of houses which clearly is a
defined comment
you've met the knee
actually
referring to a plan that has got limited
weight
why are why are referring to numbers
that is in a plan that has limited
weight where we have a joint local plan
that we don't seem to be referring to in
that regard on this matter you have to
just to take a sort of sober assessment
of the information before you and the 58
is the figure that emerges during the
jlp so that's the figure that we work
with and indeed which informs the
Holbrook neighborhood plan
when we take data from one document to
another it doesn't lessen its truth is
that correct
well I think I think I'm sure Mark is
draw a distinction I'm saying correctly
between the documents itself that's
still that's still not formally adopted
and the evidence base behind it which we
have every reason to believe is reliable
As I understood you correctly Mark there
Sam do you these questions are all meant
to be coming to you but we've received
it that's fine
it is really confusing
um we're in a state of flux at the
moment but I think it's important for
members to remember that currently
the most way is given to cs11
cs11 of our current core strategy
from that point on
less weight is given so first of all
it's the core strategy then it's the
neighborhood plan and then is the jlp so
this application actually fails cs11
because it's not meeting an identified
need which the neighborhood plan has
actually specified within its context
which is given great weight
than the mppf
actually says that as the neighborhood
plans progress
they are given more weight so we're now
on the last stage before it goes to
referendum
therefore it's given great weight in
this particular instance
thank you Sam Catherine McCall you've
got a question
um this
but officers in general can probably
comment are we not obliged in policy
terms
to take the most recent and informed
evidence as to housing need based on
information available because yes the
original core strategy dates to 2013
adopted in 2015. now it would be foolish
for us I think and just wanted to get
confirmation of this for us to be
assuming that an assessment made eight
years ago would still be current and up
to date we're constantly updating our
housing need and making Rec assessments
and surely there's actually a statutory
duty to include the most recent evidence
as to housing need in in considerations
and that's why we are describe bits of
weight to different evidence so can I
just ask if that is a good or Fair
statement of the position if we're
regarding housing needs that we don't
just throw something out of them
completely because it's not a rich
the nothing nothing is static that's why
we have emerging plans is that a fair
statement yes and that's why cs11
actually requires uh the housing needs
assessment to form part of the
application submission and when we don't
have one we refer to the neighborhood
plan because that's the most up-to-date
document that we have and cs11
specifically is adopted and fits the
bill as regards to the other questions
uh specifically states that we should
use the most recent evidence in
assessing housing need so that in fact
is up to
adopted policy
yeah we should make it clear
that the neighborhood plan isn't yet
adopted it's only been to examination
but yes it's the most recent information
that we have on the housing need in
Holbrook it's covered by the provisions
of cs11 would that be correct
I think unless Ian thinks otherwise
Chancellor Hinton
thank you Mr chairman
um well just to confuse matters even
more for everybody of course if you
looked at the local latest monitoring
report it would show that we've got four
thousand odd permissions granted across
the district which is a hell of a lot
more than we need for the next 10 years
anyway so in that on that basis we
wouldn't give anything any permission
but that doesn't work that way the
question I have for Sam is
I think you can probably see it on slide
22 but the width of the actual access
point proposed
and the width of Holmes Lane at that
point
because that shows clearly how wide a
Hiram's Lane is or not very wide times
Lane is but the artist impression if
you'd like to call it that of the
proposed access into the development
side seems to show something big enough
to act as an entrance for Tesco's isn't
it yeah so the previous application was
refused on highways ground because the
widening of the lane uh
we felt would ruin the character that
rural character or poems Lane
with this particular application they've
addressed that by cutting back the
highway badge to make the visibility
displays much better
and therefore highways did not raise an
objection to the scheme this time
so how wide is the access point
I'm afraid that I don't know the answer
to that and I'm Blaine
here wouldn't it
turned
we have the highways officer with us
would you like to
vote
help from him he's on this on the screen
on a Ben
good morning can you help with that
question about the width of the lane
and the width of the entrance
yes the
the
entrance is such a width big big because
of the lack of width of Hiram's Lane so
the
the entrance away from
radioi have to be
um large to accept the um the necessary
Vehicles because the average way width
isn't it it's limited there it widens
out towards the chip Junction which Hill
so they would be in
um
degree of the equals having to wait for
or others to pass because it arrows down
to a single track
um width close to the
the no access point
but um in terms of us objecting
um
the scale of this of the proposal and
and AllCast vehicle trips which is only
um I think it was six in the peak hour
of Maximum so
in terms of a severe impact we we we
don't have anything to to sort of hang
it on as such so um
and
even the site is proposing a a separate
footpath access on onto Church Hill
it shouldn't increase any
pedestrian usage of homes laying it in
that that um area which would be our
creator concern
thank you Ben Council Hampton you ask
the question do you want that if I could
come back and say well that that may not
be the development may not increase the
pedestrian traffic on the Hiram's Lane
but there is already existing traffic
along Highland Lane and this is going to
be impacted by the vehicles coming out
and so they're coming out of a nice big
wide entrance into a narrow little lane
it's going to cause confusion and hasn't
the change in Attitude from the county
highways uh exacerbated that situation
it's the
volume of traffic here the high arms
Lane is very quiet
as it is the applicant
um
carried out traffic
of
voluminous AIDS surveys for the
application
and the volumes of
very small it's it's a it's around
12 to 218 existing in peak hours then
this this this Pro proposal
on onto this section in in the e-course
we're still only talking about
um sort of across the peak hour would
only be one vehicle every three minutes
or so so it it it's not something that
we could
could uphold an objection on
you Ben can't see anything you've ever
yeah
yeah existing pedestrian and cycle and
potential equestrian traffic that might
be going down there you can measure
Vehicles yes uh but there are other
other forms of Transport should we say
that are using that lane
which were increasing at certain times
and they're more at risk if you like
than vehicles are
yeah it it's also worth noting that that
proposed footpath
connection onto on onto Church Hill cook
would also be used by by the
Eastern pedestrian traffic
thank you Ben
are there any more questions for the
officer
no
and that thank you very much Sam
and we will
we will move on
I understand we have representative in
the
Parish Council Mr John Ambrose
you have three minutes to address the
committee
my name is John Ambrose and chairman of
the Holbrook Parish Council Aubrey
Parish Council objects to this
application and we have objected to the
previous three applications on this site
which have all been refused we also
believe the reasons for refusal
for those applications are still valid
and equally applied to this application
the reasons for our objections can
broadly be summarized as firstly the
application is in conflict with our
newly examined neighborhood plan
secondly the access is inappropriate and
unsafe both during construction and also
when the development is completed
thirdly the environmental impact of this
application
to achieve the required width of the
lane and to achieve the required
visibility would result in unacceptable
heteroblasts and damage to the roots and
trees and loss of immunity to adjoining
residence fourthly the housing proposed
does not meet the identified needs in of
the parish and there is no affordable
housing included
Holbrook began its neighborhood of a
planned journey in 2018 and undertaken
considerable public consultation
Community engagement and evidence
gathered to support the development over
the number of years this has come
this has seen the plan
been successful at the independent
examiner and the examiner issued her
reports on the 20th of February
recommending we're going forward to the
referendum both Parish Council and baber
District Council are happy with
modifications suggested by The Examiner
and we're now waiting the referendum the
work of the plan means we are clear on
the views of the local community and we
know that this proposal is not
consistent with the views expressed
this is a local people are in favor of
affordable housing that meets ident
local needs such as affordable housing
and Bungalows the Paris is incredibly
sensitive in terms of its environment
both its landscaped through the area of
outstanding natural beauty designation
and its Wildlife through
the various designation the area is so
sensitive that environmental screening
of the neighborhood plan has been
undertaken twice and this resulted in
changes to our draft policy wording
even very small levels of development
can potentially have a detrimental
effect on the environment of the parish
you will see from the committee papers
that post-examination labor plan is to
be afforded you wait in decision making
and has
significant bearing on this application
the recommendation of refusal is the
correct one and is supported by the
parish council thank you
are there any questions for the parish
council Council advice for your hand was
up first
yeah you identified this as not a site
that you want to bring forward in the
neighborhood plan do you have any sites
that you've have identified to fill the
Gap that we've seen in the numbers
yes um we have a site so throughout the
village identified
but this was not put forward during the
consultation or the co-author sites
and uh some a site adjacent to it was um
was recommended by akong as not suitable
sorry so you've got enough sites to
cover the short form of the numbers that
are identified yes we have okay uh Just
one thought we keep talking about this
site not producing the right mix of
housing if a proposal came forward for
say four two-bedroom Bungalows a couple
of one bedroom flats and two or three
two bedroomed houses a foot which could
be affordable would that change your
view in terms of the uh acceptability of
the size
um no because the site is outside the
area of the uh
The Village Development and even
changing mix of the housing would
um
not comply with the requirements we've
still have the issue with accessibility
and the damage to the environment
thank you for answering the question you
needn't have answered
councilor Barrett yeah I clearly under
by your presentation and your um
what do you put on the uh on our papers
here that the town the parish council
clearly has uh concerns regarding the
highways that seems to be your main
concern
and no it's not just the just that it's
the fact that he doesn't meet the
housing needs identified in the
neighborhood plan
yeah because it would be difficult to
actually go against the recommendation
of the County Council wouldn't it as the
highways Authority
I mean you you've listed many
um
reasons traffic reasons but of course we
sort of tend to have to dismiss those
because we have to take the
recommendation of the highways the
experts so although you're obviously
putting that down and it to me you've
given a great deal of weight to the
traffic and the access
but of course we we have experts opinion
from just now that says that that isn't
an issue
and the traffic volumes are very low in
that lane
so
question please the question is
are you being unrealistic
with your objections on traffic and
access
when when we hear from the experts that
that isn't an issue
I can only speak as somebody who lives
locally and often walks alone and I know
from personal experience it is a very
con very narrow Lane and it's not just
traffic
that we're objecting to as the officer
mentioned that the neighborhood plan
policies to one and two are not met by
this development
thank you
councilor hold
sites have you got in your emerging
neighborhood plan
for development
I believe it's four
and are they all within the error
settlement boundary
uh yes I believe so
can we get confirmation from an officer
boys confirmed in our papers
find it please Sam just to confirm that
but I think it was confirmed in the
papers
I seem to remember me reading it until I
read it it's got to be there
right while we're doing that any more
questions
no thank you very much
we now have
an objector
Mr Simon poncho
I hope I've pronounced that correctly
um you have three minutes to address the
committee uh good morning yes my name is
Simon Quantrill and I live at
brackenwood homes Lane I'm speaking on
behalf of my neighbors in Highlands Lane
and on Church Hill as we all object this
application I hope you received my email
yesterday from which you will know I
want to persuade persuade you that this
planning application should be refused
because it's the wrong development in
the wrong place
we are pleased that the committee report
recommends that planning permission
should be refused because in terms the
application does not represent
sustainable development and does not
comply with the policy cs11 and the
emerging joint local plan policy sp03
and importantly policy is 01 and O2 of
the recently examined Holbrook
neighborhood plan because essentially
the proposed development is outside of
the settlement boundary putting it in
direct conflict with these policies
paragraph 13.7 of the committee report
confirms that there are no material
considerations that allow you to ignore
these policies and permit you to Grant
permission
however there are other planning reasons
why you should refuse permission and
these include the fact that heim's lane
is a much-loved quiet single-track
Country Lane no more than four meters
wide at the entrance used by so many
people for walking running and cycling
that is why the new access road at the
narrowest part of Palms Lane would
create traffic increased traffic
conflict between cars pedestrians and
cyclists it would also harm the Royal
character of the lane especially because
of the amount of construction Works
required to cut into the one and a half
meter Banks which exist contrary to the
pictures from the developer
we wish to challenge Suffolk highways
recent about face to allow the access
road to be built with reduced visibility
splays
even though Holmes Lane is such a narrow
road the only reason given for this
change was the assumption that there's
no parking in heims Lane but in reality
there is and we have shown you that with
our photographs all previous Highway
requirements quoted the standard Force
specification for visibility splays it
would be wrong and dangerous to allow
substandard visibility displays now
the impact of the fire station has been
greatly underestimated any new residents
would soon complain about the noise
water spray and light interference
from my own experience there is an
ongoing odor problem from the waste
treatment plant no oral assessment has
been provided
I can assure you that the first two
houses on the proposed site will
definitely experience the same problems
as we do from odor
in 2021
planning consent was refused for a new
access at the same location because the
proposal due to its location scale
layout and the necessary Works which
would be required to provide a safe
access would be detrimental to the rural
character of Home slave please accept
today the recommendation of the
committee report and refuse planning
permission today for the same reasons as
given in 2021 nothing has changed
thank you my question sir you stated
that um the access was substandard yes
um
I was under the impression that the
highways Authority have accepted that
this is acceptable displays have been
done so can I have that confirmed by our
officers or somebody as to whether it is
substandard or whether the experts
Highway
um Department uh are saying this is okay
you know that that's what my waste
member has said I know what the highways
question but I want it confirmed in this
room because it was accused it was
substandard now it may be substandard I
want to know whether the gentleman there
is right or not thank him but the
judgment is entitled to his opinion
agree and I think we can confirm
we confirmed from Sam that that the
highway should say this is okay yeah
highways have raised no objection to
this scheme
for clarification you're asking whether
highways have relaxed their standards
and I think we're gonna have to ask them
that because
I haven't objected we'll stick to our
asking questions to the objector we'll
come back to that when we reach to the
debate stage
thank you any more questions for the
objective
can I answer
can if you think you need to
the reality is is that Suffolk highways
have changed their position over the
last three years and including on this
planning application about what's
required originally and until quite
recently they required homes Lane to be
widened but when the objections were met
and they accepted that widening heims
Lane would remove all the Hedge and all
the trees which was unacceptable they
then asked for the
um
thank thank you Council Council Barrett
um I'll remind you I'm chairing the
meeting not you
um on the point of order and
clarification Mr chairman the comments
just made if we asked our highways
officer great comment on that I mean
Communications now within Council of BSA
who'll give a response in a minute we
will get a response thank you I'm so
happy to hear what the the member of the
public saying that I I may want it
confirmed or denied or whatever by the
highways officer because this is an
important point we're always told and
and we object like you use our objective
and lots of the applications that we
don't agree with the highways but
they're we're told it's the experts and
we cannot alter it
chance to reply on the difference
between what he said and what the
official advice was and I think I'm not
sure what his answer is I think we must
let him finish yeah sure yeah
thank you the point I'm making is that
for all of the applications which have
been previously refused
the full specification for the standard
visibility display of
um the X dimension of 2.4 meters and the
Y dimension of 43 meters can
genital to the near side edge of the
carriageway was required here late in
the day I January this year highways
have said okay the only way we can allow
this now is to allow you to have reduced
visibility displays we all narrow those
but let's do
it doesn't make sense because they've
required for the last three years in all
previous applications the full
specification of their standard
visibility display now on the narrowest
part of arms Lane they're suggesting it
will be safe to have a much reduced
visibility display and they justify that
on the basis that there's no car parking
in heims Lane but we've subject we have
produced evidence photographic evidence
to demonstrate that there's regularly
cars parking and Pines laying close to
the proposed access site which will cost
a chairman I'm sorry to interrupt I
think you're now allowing a debate by a
member of the public of our committee
meeting
thank you Council bear
please mark yes respond yep thank you Mr
control um I can confirm yes it's
correct that they did change their
position
we had a meeting I can't remember back
in the last year or early this year with
highways ad with the AO and B team
because there was a there's antagonism
between the landscape and the highway
safety as you know it just kept going
backwards and forwards so got them into
a meeting to say is this achievable in
any way at all and the highway
authorities position was that they they
changed their position basically they
relaxed their views and that was in part
based on the speech every result
so the answer I've got here from the
highway Authority is that I asked our
display substandard and the response was
they're in accordance with the speed
server results and the only adjustment
is due to the width of the lane being
single track
so it was a speed survey in terms of the
conversation about the parking which
you've presented to them and they seem
to not respond to I can't answer that
but in terms of the displays it was the
speed survey that informed that the
issue of the parking is in Bank check
please please wait
thank you Mark
I think
you've had the opportunity to make your
point I think we've got to the situation
where the highways have changed their
minds
to you object and you have every right
to do so and you've expressed those
yourself today
thank you I think we better move on
are there any more questions for the
objective
no right
thank you
we now have a supporter Mr Williams
Saunders
you have three minutes to address the
committee
thank you Mr chairman good morning uh
yes I'm William Saunders I live in
Holbrook
um I strongly support this application I
I speak for many in the village of
Holbrook who would really like to see an
imaginative housing scheme such as this
um the village and hope for the larger
District can be proud of by way of
background I moved into Holbrook with my
family uh young family and my wife five
years ago at a time of moving we faced a
very limited choice of Housing and
finally decided on the new development
at Admirals quarter we enjoy all that
Holbrook has to offer young families and
we Wrigley walk and cycle around the
village but if this scheme had been
available to us five years ago we had
perhaps been there much sooner than we
were and because this scheme has been
signed lights sidelined so many times
other families like us are being denied
the opportunity to move to Holbrook
the Holbrook neighborhood plan has
identified that truly affordable
property either to buy or to rent is
necessary
necessary to keep the younger generation
in the village
this application is offering
well-designed property to rent and the
opportunity to address the government's
Target to self-build
there are so many big and Anonymous
developments shooting up all around us
particularly on the edge of Ipswich but
in a village environment we want to
encourage small schemas such as this one
which enhances the community the the
houses are designed to pick up local
features with thoughtful landscape
surroundings
alluding to what I believe was
previously a an orchard the new
residents would be close to established
neighbors and Facilities but discreetly
screen from the traffic on the main road
I would suggest there's a wonderful
opportunity for labor councilors and
officers to get behind this fantastic
scheme in my opinion and designed by an
award-winning architect and I fully
Deport it and I think we could have
something here that we'd be very proud
of
thank you
thanks um are you aware of the
neighborhood plan have you have you read
the name of London I have but please
don't ask me to go into depth and to to
the specifics of it but I yes I have and
and we were we were part of that
consultation good okay you've heard that
there were four sites that have been put
forward by The Village
yes indeed
um
would you prefer this site over any of
the four that have been put forward and
if so why well this one is the only one
that I have
witnessed being developed and I had seen
the plans of in such detail as you've
shown here and for for the reasons that
I've said that young family etc etc
these are appealing developments that
would uh would would attract similar uh
people to the area in my my belief
obviously slightly differently if the
other four were developed would there be
a need for this one being the fifth
four I'm not sure how close they are to
being developed at what stage they're at
um this one may be further down the line
than the others
um so it's a difficult question to
answer
that should be here
thank you Mr chairman
um the point you made
um in in your comments was that um you
felt this would encourage local people
and more young people coming into the
Village
um
it's rather good to hear that's a side
view because often we don't hear that
how competent are you of that particular
comment you made well certainly in uh
Holbrook and the surrounding area
affordable housing for young
professionals is extremely difficult to
come by
um I worked at the Royal Hospital school
before so I didn't have that problem
until actually I finished work there and
thought well where can I move to and and
the the opportunities the options of
extremely Limited
thank you councilman cruel
sorry about that um
thanks very much for putting your
thoughts forward Mr Saunders um you've
stated that
we need you need in Holbrook affordable
housing but isn't isn't it true that
this is actually full market value
whether that be a market rent or or
market value for purchase
yes I I imagine so as was the house that
that we bought as well on Admiral
quarter
okay that just so interesting there's a
difference here in affordable and I know
what affordable actually means in even
uh planning terms eight times but uh the
average wage around here as opposed to
11 but um
can I ask and I hope you don't mind but
I think it's a reasonable question do
you have any connection with the
applicants in any way because you know
we always have to declare if we have any
conflict of interests
there's no conflict we work together a
long while ago but that is it so you you
know I know yes absolutely and and you
say you were you involved in the um
as a consultee in the local neighborhood
plan yes uh were you a member of the
local neighborhood plan Planning Group
of any way
um so do you generally approve of the
neighborhood plan for Holbrook I approve
of it because it's a fantastic area
which needs
as I said uh uh plans in it having
encouraging people of my age and younger
into the area to make it sustainable and
Thrive and develop I'm just a little
confused it sounds like you do approve
of the neighborhood plan just not one of
the specifics of the neighborhood of the
plan which is specifically the two
policies referred to in the planning
application that does seem slightly
strange Mr chairman I'm a kind of order
I do not think the the planner member
has the right to interrogate
and that's what it sounds like to me
you're entitled to your opinion of the
other members questions I don't think he
was causing any offense at all
no offense no I'm trying to understand
what the point is of it
right exactly
thank you specifically the point is that
a neighborhood plan is is possibly about
to be made but has certainly gone
through a process and I just wondered
that if you didn't see a little bit of
conflict in in accepting the principle
of a neighborhood plan but not one of
its main specific policies but then as
as you've said already the neighborhood
plan hasn't been adopted yet
no at that point
thank you
any more questions
come to the halt have you got any
questions
have I no thank you for asking though
thank you if I may just take quickly I I
I'm not saying councilman across
question across any boundaries that's
not for me to say but I think just that
we we've always
Porter is
a member of the community who supports
the application we've generally
discouraged the slot being taken by a
family member or an employee but there's
no hard and fast Rule and there's no
to make the same declarations that
members are mainly make
I apologize if that was the way it came
across
thank you Ian thank you sir
we now have the applicant
Cassie showman you have three minutes to
address the committee
it's Kristoff
um who is first addressing the committee
okay
we're sharing duties okay three minutes
between you yeah thank you hi I'm
Kristoff director of task architects
proposal before you is a thoughtful
small scale application for a mixed
range of housing which includes good
quality two-bit Properties Plus larger
three and four mil bedroom self-build
Lots
this mix was chosen in response to the
local needs plan at the time back in
this planning application was submitted
in March 2021 exactly two years ago
the suggested entrance to the site
extends only slightly further west than
the existing houses to the south of
Hines Lane namely brackenwood whose
gardened outbuildings in fact extend
well to the west of The Proposal site
it should be noted that this site
strategy has the support of Suffolk
highways
the existing land is overgrown with no
visual or ecological Merit it is wedged
between residential homes to the north
and houses to the east and south it is
scruffy Bramble hijacked infill
territory which we think can be enhanced
with a beautiful landscape proposal
encompassing a two meter deep landscape
buffer a communal Orchard to replace the
fruit trees that used to be on the site
and some well-designed carefully
positioned homes
it is encouraging to note that the
planning office includes that the
development does not have any adverse
impact on the character or appearance of
the area
it is an established principle of
planning law that there must be harm
arising from a development to justify
withholding permission
we've looked closely at the surrounding
vernacular and created a mix of
contemporary sustainable homes with a
muted natural pallet to complement the
area
a recent project of ours not dissimilar
to this one one arriba award in 2021
where the judge commented if more
backland sites were developed with this
level of rigor and Delight we reduce the
housing crisis and improve the fabric of
our towns and cities in equal measure
this scheme is a great opportunity to
create something beyond the standard of
red brick houses one sees so regularly
sprinkled around our Countryside
and to build houses that will continue
to evolve and enhance the area for years
to come
what this proposal is not is a large
development by faceless National
developer producing the same houses no
matter where they are in the country
this is a small local scheme that we
feel should be supported to improve the
quality and variety of housing for
people who are Keen to live in this
amazing place as well as maybe become a
positive example to encourage other
smaller house builders to engage more in
their local communities
to create the broad mix of housing that
this country needs thank you good
morning I'm Kathy Shelbourne
co-owner with my brother of the land at
Holbrook where we grew up my mother was
a school Governor my father a church
Warden over the decades they contributed
enormously to the community we are very
disappointed that our application has
been constantly bypassed here is a
scheme with attractive homes to rent and
plots for self-builders and the
opportunity for the Next Generation to
become part of that Holbrook community
that we grew up in
sorry
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions for the applicant
councilor beer
um thank you Mr chairman
um just to the last speaker
um the South build I think that's a very
uh good scheme going forward
have you had much sort of Interest or
have you had any comments from the the
local people who may want to buy or just
locals generally because
local build is is a good idea and I
think you can get such a wonderful
selection from from Bungalows to small
dwellings to larger dwellings so have
you had any of that thank you
sorry it hasn't been widely publicized
so at the moment it's just
on paper but I would say that the houses
to the north of our plot were self-built
as well they were three self-builders
and you know hopefully they've become
part of the fabric of the community too
thank you
um yeah the uh obviously one of the
reason this is being refused is that
apparently there was no housing needs
survey what I'm asking is as this
application went in in 2021 we
presumably you were basing your
need on that point then in time
we refer to the um the local needs plan
that was that was
the time and at that time what did that
show or demonstrate it demonstrated from
my understanding of it that we needed or
the whole needed I live in the area too
so I'm
uh there was a there was there was a
need for smaller two-bed houses that
were sort of more affordable not
necessarily affordable in the planning
sense but more affordable for
um for younger families so the time you
put the application in
you uh
basically fulfilling the housing need
that's what we thought we felt is that
you that's what you felt is that what
you were told by the officers at the
time uh that was our reading of the
local needs plan
okay yeah there was the other point I've
got
um which came up from the objectors or
not for injectors but um the obviously
neighborhood plan
uh did you try and submit
your scheme to the parish council in
their neighborhood plan and so you did
submit it to them I talked to
Parish Council oh
that was a while ago and we had a good
chat
um
and and obviously it was a positive chat
because we didn't go away and not submit
it
thank you
any more questions
I think that's a very good point Simon
um it's a good question so when you'd
have this chat were you surprised that
your site wasn't included therefore in
the initial neighborhood plan
consultation
that um
that we didn't have more support
you know it is a jolly good scheme
hey sorry chair I don't know if it's
possible to I can see the chair of
Parish Council is Keen to answer the
question which I'd like to ask him which
is why didn't you include it in your
neighborhood plan
if I think it will get to the bottom
line we'll have a go
sir would you like to briefly answer
that if you can
um yes certainly
um first of all we're addressing the
console um the telephone conversation
um it's a written policy in the parish
council that no
um
discussions pre submission and planning
applications
um
takes on no formal discussions take
place and certainly there was an
informal discussion and I've I'd recall
that it was said that it should go to um
to the parish council when these the
application was submitted in response to
the
sites for the neighborhood plan there
was a great deal of effort made to court
for a call for site and at the time of
that there was no submission by the
applicant of this site for inclusion in
the neighborhood plan and since the
sites were evaluated Acom did indicate
that if it was submitted as a site it
would have been
identified as not suitable
thank you
Mr chairman give the load the parish
council to come back quite rightly
um I think the applicant I'd like to
know what their comments is on that on
those last statement from the parish
council because it's important let's
finish any more questions and then we
can go back to that point if you would
remind me are there any more questions
right
you would now like oh I I would like
um the applicant the lady and the
gentleman the back there uh to comment
on what what they've heard about their
conversations with the Paris Council and
how they interpreted it and how it was
um not sort of put in the local plan and
what have you
you're going to try and put it in the
form of a question that might help
clarify the situation if it is true that
the applicants didn't put the site
forward
um can I ask if they did or um why they
didn't I think that's the question isn't
it Jeff
thank you it wasn't put forward in in
the call for sites because previous
Applications had been made although they
had been refused it was felt that the
application this current application
could address those um failings
and I'd like to point out that this
application was being supported by the
council uh up until about two weeks ago
when the emerging local plan came out so
it's been two years of support we
expected to come to committee with
support from the the planning department
uh to be told two weeks ago that that
support was being withdrawn as a result
of this new low high data plan thank you
very much
surroundings directly and you were
making a general point that if somebody
in the village Rings you up as a
chairman and says what do you think
about two houses in this location you
would as a match
oh that sounds a jolly good idea oh
dearly how terrible you'd say You must
approach us formally is that right yes
that's correct so there is a policy
adopted by the parish council that
um
whilst somebody can informally approach
us we do not
um that doesn't
um get taken as supporting the
application it must come to the council
for consideration
yes
and thank you very much
for your case
we now go on to the ward member
councilman McLaren you've stood down and
committed to be the award member you
have five minutes to address the
committee
thank you chair
I hope everybody can hear me
councilor boss bill was complains he
can't
sorry I'm as near as I can cancel a beer
um in 2020 and I made some comments
about the application that was going
forward at the time and I will just read
out the reasons why the reasons I gave
at that point none of the proposed
housing meets The Wider need of all the
residents and their families who wish to
remain in Holbrook that we have many
local Holbrook families who cannot
afford to live in the village because
there is a dearth of affordable housing
and we've also got many elderly
residents who could downsize but can't
so there's a shortage of single story
dwellings as well which means that young
people and families have to move away
because there is no accommodation they
can afford this is a great loss to a
rural community in economic and social
terms
this site brings no
economic benefit to the larger Community
because the development is quite small
the fire station with its proximity to
the site regularly undertakes night
drills
higham slain is a one car with Country
Lane for Walkers children cyclists dog
walkers and visitors
very large projects undertaken by
anglian water in 2020 at the entrance of
papayans Lane for many weeks confirmed
the inadequacy of the main Highway and
higham's Lane to deal with any increase
in traffic especially
um
heavy traffic
residents live in opposite the proposed
size to entrance have to live with
vehicles used in the space in front of
their houses to away oncoming traffic to
pass
the potential for accidents remains from
the construction of this site and the
increased traffic onto the lane and to
and from the site by residents that was
a comments I made in 2020 they have not
changed those are fundamentally not
changed in 2023 we have seen the
photographic evidence of the light
pollution from the fire station during
their regular nitriles which would
intrude into the post site and affect
the residents
I personally use this Lane quite
frequently and since the pandemic and
the increase of online shopping the
number of delivery Vans traveling from
touching Stone to Holbrook across the
countryside merging into high and slain
has increased dramatically
Holbrook is a core Village needs young
families and older people and we need to
be attracting those groups into our
village
otherwise they have to move elsewhere
I will mention that baber already has a
7.13 year housing Supply so this housing
is not needing
as a council as bayborough District
Council we encourage the developments of
the neighborhood plan and Holbrook have
been rewarded for all their hard work
and are now in a position that the
examiner has recommended that the plan
goes to referendum and the wait has
changed in relation to the consideration
of this application thank you chair
thank you members and request that the
committee considered the officer's
recommendation
thank you Council McLaren any questions
foreign
thank you Mary um
a 7.13 year housing Supply therefore the
housing isn't needed
before that you said that houses were
needed in the village and they
particular type which is affordable
small houses for families I would have
thought these two bedroom properties
were exactly there
must be I rather confuse the um the
argument I quite agree I was just making
the point that the district has a that
land Supply but that all of our Villages
actually are in need of affordable
housing and single story dwellings
because the population
the demographic of the population is
changing so I'm sorry I confused you
nope thank you very much Council McLaren
debate
check I'll come back on a couple of
points you may
thanks just before you start debate um
the question was asked about site
allocations in the Holbrook neighbor
plan unless I'm getting this very wrong
um I think the conclusion was that there
were no allocations because it's based
on the fact that already been an over
provision I'm just going to read you the
relevant uh paragraph from the I would
plan
which is
um
with me
lost it of course
um
so yeah it's paragraph 3.8 of their
planned but it's actually quoted in our
paragraph 3.10 the committee report
and
towards the end of that the last three
lines therefore the parish is not
compelled to make any further
allocations to meet this target prior to
2037.
so my understanding is that there aren't
any allocated sites because there's
already an over provision
I stand to be corrected by people
shouting at me but that's my
understanding of that
and what's the other point uh the other
point was relating to splays um I've
been in touch with uh Ben Chester for
the Iowa Authority so it spun from the
discussion about parked cars Etc
um then goes on to say the adjustment
where we compromise is simply moving
displays out from the near side edge
into the road
and we base this on the narrow width of
the road where and I quote the
likelihood of cars being completely on
the wrong side of the road is minimal or
impossible
um also worth noting the speed survey
results are 27.3 miles an hour and
that's based on the speed so that's
that's the average speed cars go up
there according to this survey
so they wouldn't
a three meter splay and it's a location
where the criteria for reduction from
2.4 to 2 meter setback would be accepted
we compromised slightly because we felt
we wouldn't be able to defend an
objection on visibility if challenged
thank you
uh well one other anybody wants to ask
Mark a question of clarification from
what is just said
Council I hope you were up first
yeah on the numbers
is this the number
with permissions
or the number that have been built
yeah so the number sorry the numbers
we're looking at the those those said to
be required was 58 and the number built
I think 60
built or they have permission 69.
permission not built
that's my understanding yeah
about me you know
um Mark could you just confirm so
am I reading then that the
neighborhood plan is actually
recommending that no development takes
place
on the basis that development numbers
have been hit
up until 2037. well it can't do that
because that would be nppf compliant but
it's no it's got an unless if you look
at the Innovation po1 there's a there's
a hook there um
where it's it's the fourth paragraph
down I can see you can't outside the
Divine settlement boundaries proposals
for new housing including conversion
self-build replacement will only be
permitted without in accordance with
national District level policies so that
takes us around to cs11 a need basically
go in a bit of a circle come back to
needing it
right okay
counselor McGraw
let's ask a question of of Mark as the
area planning merger on a technical
matter in that
um the recommendation in the papers
doesn't include some changes perhaps
that should be made to it and under this
uh additional correction for the joint
local plan uh are we going to be making
amendments to the recommendation I I
think I may I may have possibly said
that at the bottom of the table papers
but we'll do that we'll just add a line
in and also contrary to so that would be
specifically referring to emergence
emerging policy spo3 in conjunction with
cs11 indeed is that correct I think we
have to do that in passing anyway
because as as things progress as appeals
emerge these matters are come to us
anyway so both those policies address
the same issue don't they cs-11 and spo3
they are in fact equivalent but once
differ the more recent one spo3 is a
little more rigorous than cs11 is that
right
I think it is I think we're going back
almost to the lockdown on settlement
limits basically and we're not there yet
but it is it is more students cs11 is
more flexible policy certainly
thank you
Johnson possibly have a question for the
planning man every man thanks
with the uh have the neighborhood plan
which is this is a document that is
top of the waiting in terms of which
documents we should give
I'm confused as to what's in it either
they have four sites allocated
or they haven't
if they haven't
it's a whole new different look on the
neighborhood plan
do and Nick before I make any decision I
want to know what is the truth on this
neighborhood plan
I think the important thing to realize
the examiner found it to be sound
basically so on the judgment about
housing need the examiner found in favor
of what suggesting so I think that's the
shortcut answer to the examiner finds in
favor
that's fine
but it says also that in here that there
will be windfall sites
that will be considered
um if you've got four sites allocated
for future development
the requirement from windfall is almost
eliminated if you haven't got any sites
then you are going to be dependent on
and
according to the figures
they've already had
the housing
that they're required to have has
already been built yet there is still a
need for certain types of housing
so where's this need going to be
fulfilled is it from windfall is it from
the four sites that have been supposedly
allocated
or what we can't make a decision
given this gray area of waiting without
some facts certainly gray areas give you
that and the case officer wants to set
up
you have an extract of text from the
neighborhood plan my reading of that is
um
well the emerging local plan also
identified a minimum housing requirement
for the Parish of 65 new dwellings over
the plan period to 2037.
this housing requirement is already met
as it primarily comprises sites that
have the benefit of planning permission
and were not implemented at the first of
April 2018
58 dwellings so I suspect what has
happened
is the the settlement boundary has been
redrawn in line with the jlp what
appeared in that document to include
those sites that were previously
acceptable under cs11
had permission they haven't been
implemented I think that's probably the
four sites that the parish council are
trying to explain that they feel are
allocated sites so they weren't
previously within the settlement
boundary the settlement boundary is
being redrawn so the planning permission
can be
applied for again for those sites that
were acceptable previously
but maybe the parish council can
can tell me if that these are the right
understanding of that or not
can you
I'm not entirely sure if I can but
certainly
there was a lot development Holbrook
since the housing need was identified
and that was met and exceeded and also
there are
that's been four houses built since then
and there's also been planning
permission granted for seven more houses
in
I'm not sure if
the settlement boundary has been adapted
and perhaps planning officers can I've
got the answer now sorry thank you
manager Holbrook neighborhood plan
paragraphs 6.12 to 6.14 this can take me
out two minutes to read through please
forgive me
um eight sites were identified in the
um site assessment this includes seven
sites within the neighborhood plan call
for sites and one from District Council
call for sites
three of the sites submitted through the
neighborhood plan had already been
submitted to mid-suffolk to the Sheila
the Strategic housing land availability
assessment all sites are available
as they have all either been submitted
to a local Authority or a neighborhood
call for sites this is very waffely one
site in Holbrook was included with a
revised site boundary so that answers
that their boundary was I don't know
which side it was but that was it was
revised one site within the pan area was
found to be potentially suitable and
available for allocation
this was however not for housing but
instead for education
all other sites were rated Red by Acom
and therefore deemed unsuitable for
residential housing
so we've got we've got three sites that
came through basically our call for
sites uh were the three sites have made
it through basically and there are no
extra sites in the neighborhood plan
no no
Mark I thought the the neighborhood plan
did have well there's three sites but
they they duplicate what was already in
in the um right in our own call for
sites so it depends how you take that
but
there were no additional to that no
thank you
all right well I'll open
let's open the debate Council Busby you
had your hand up yeah I think
clear as mud quite frankly
um I'm almost to likely to suggest that
we defer this until we can get some
actual detail as to what has been built
and what was requested to be built I
would like to know from 2018
how many houses have been built and what
they were in terms of uh two three four
bedroom houses how many houses have been
approved and not been built and the same
two three four five bedroomed houses
whatever
and
what other sites there are available and
how many houses they could accommodate
this that patient depends so much on the
neighborhood plan because without that
neighborhood plan I think it sails
through there are so many uh the
objections seem to have been overcome
and it doesn't seem to be that any other
reason to refuse it other than it
doesn't comply with a neighborhood plan
and I'm all in favor of Naval plans and
if if I was making the decision now I
would support refusal big because of the
strength of the neighborhood plan trumps
everything else
but if I haven't got confidence in that
neighborhood
label and the numbers
then I can't
come up with a decision so I propose
that we defer this and until we've
actually got the numbers that we need to
see what housing has been built what
housing is proposed and what housing is
needed is that proposal yes
thank you so we
I have a closer from Council Busby and
proposal from Council Baron seconded by
Council Farah
um
first
Council in
thank you Mr chairman reading through
Page 27 of our report I know there's
lots of figures on
identifier fairly definite
housing provision
paragraph 3.10 local merging local plan
also identifies the minimum housing
requirement for the Parish of 65 new
dwellings so there's a requirement in
the neighborhood plan for 65.
then the the page then goes on to say as
mentioned in paragraph 9.3 of the
neighborhood plan examiner's report
housing provision in Holbrook from April
2018 to March 2022 now stands at 69
dwellings in total so that's four more
than a neighborhood plan said was the uh
was required to start off with
it then goes up
what's going to do uh it goes you then
go on to say that um on paragraph 3.14
an 87 unit development in Holbrook that
is close to completion it's expected to
deliver 15 units of affordable rented
housing 12 shared ownership units this
goes some way to meet the affordable
housing need of 31 affordable rented
units and 64 affordable cell units over
the MP period so they're nearly at
the targets set by The Neighborhood Plan
before the thing's actually even been
adopted
so there is obviously no need
sorry chair can I just pick up on that
exact point if you're looking at 3.14
it says an 87 unit development in Hobart
it's close to completion he's expected
to deliver 15 units
of affordable rented housing
but there's 31 affordable rented needed
and 12 shared ownership and 64 are
needed so it isn't supplying all of the
need
total in total of how
they've built more than they've needed
but as we've discussed it's not meeting
the housing need
a crucial point this point saying yes
we've built 155 bedroomed houses if they
need 40 one bedroom Flats
because numbers mean nothing and
confusion there is a German because of
course further earlier on the point that
I made about the mentioning a
neighborhood plan examiner's report now
stands at 69 dwellings in total because
and say affordable dwellings affordable
to rent or affordable to buy or anything
else it just talks about a total of 69
dwellings so where this affordable goes
some way to meet the affordable housing
need of 31 affordable rented and 64
affordable sale units where that figure
has actually come from I'm not quite
sure it's my
let's see if I can clarify that
confusion with the area planning manager
sorry what actually is the question
chair
if you if you wanted as a straight
question
um where does the figure in paragraph
3.14 of the report which says that there
is a new that there is a requirement for
64 affordable sale units and 31
affordable renting units over the over
the neighborhood plan period actually
come from
I'd have to root around to give an
answer to that chair so okay
go to Barrett
just like to remind everyone here
there is a minimum requirement
there is no upper limit it's a minimum
requirement and it is for quite a long
period of time
so
I don't you know it's a minimum housing
requirement it doesn't there's no
maximum that's applied
so where does where does this sort of
come in that we have a ceiling because
there is no ceiling it's a minimum
requirement because if you put a if you
actually put a ceiling on it within the
neighborhood plan then it would get
kicked out
thank you
Council rowing I've got a five minute
break why not fine throughout please
have a closer
let's carry on with the discussion while
he does that
no we just
I have it on the table
I don't have to take the vote yet
because I suspect that this time if I do
you'll lose but but um I I think we'll
allow
yes you can thanks chair
um
I think a lot of red herrings flying
around in this chamber today we've heard
a lot of discussion about uh the
highways issues on higham's Lane I
accept the that's been a concern but
it's not actually part of the argument
for refusal on this case
um that has whether right or wrong has
been put to one side by Officer advice I
would just like to say I'm inclined in
all of this to support the policies now
the whole point of supporting these
policies and and again another red
herring previous applications did not
have the jlp carrying the same weight
they did not have the
Holbrook neighborhood plan carrying the
same weight as they do now we have
increased weight and I'm inclined to
support policy because there are some
quite specific reasons why
recommendation is given particularly in
policies hnp01 and hnp02
um and the fact that our own
jlpsp03 seems to strengthen cs-11 so
there are specific reasons that actually
describe the recommendation in a way
that can be consistent with the nppf and
with our own policies and
every time we make a decision we've got
to bear in mind that we may be required
to defend that position so if we're
going to defend the position we need to
have a good policy basis not vague
instances let's take another red herring
that keeps coming up
the requirement for having site
allocations there is no requirement in a
neighborhood plan to actually have site
allocations any longer it was a one-time
perhaps thought to be so but it isn't
and I think a number of neighborhood
plans are coming forward without any
allocations now in this instance we've
got an allocation for a community that
has been met and possibly exceeded and
yes it's quite right it can be exceeded
but if we're going to talk about the
arguments presented to us today I asked
do we have enough information to make a
decision and I believe we do without
getting if you don't mind my saying
sidetracked in some of these red
herrings and I take the point mode I
think there are some issues but I don't
think they're as important or relevant I
think we have the information we need to
make a sound decision and and that's
probably the way I shall vote
thank you
so members the vote for a deferral is
now in progress uh councilor beer can I
take your vote please for the deferment
thank you
so chair that's five votes against the
Jim Farrell and five votes for a
deferral
and please ask for your casting my
casting vote before you before you say
that can I just say that the deferment
could be after
next application it might only be an
hour
I'm sorry we've taken the vote the next
step is I have to make a casting vote
and I'm against the deferral
let's move on
forms and
councilor Henson would you like to
continue we've
gone round around in circles a little
bit on this one but I would like to try
and speed things along a bit by
proposing the officer's recommendations
I've set out in the paper
thank you councilman councilman are you
secondly at the second thank you very
much yeah I just need to add in the line
about the reference to the jlp in the
reason of refusal okay
okay fine with that added to it Council
Holt
yeah I don't fit in the position to be
able to
um
really consider this matter I think
we're lacking in evidence I think we're
lacking in answers to questions and I'm
very concerned that we're going down
this road as members we should be
presented with everything that we need
and I don't feel in this instance we
have been
and I think it's very concerning going
forward
thank you
any more comments
then I'll ask
the area manager to sum up what this
motion exactly is
yes I think I've got an answer to that
affordable the reference to 64 well that
says 65 here baby is yet to publish a
revised part two of the emerging jlp
or to publish any revised supporting
documentation a record this is for the
examiner I recognize the figure of a
minimum of 65 dwellings does not address
the affordable housing need identified
in the Holbrook Parish housing needs
assessment however 65 is a minimum
figure and that's talking about
affordable so that's where that
reference
just to clear up that confusion I'd hope
at this point there's nothing else that
hasn't been answered but I'm happy to uh
before we move I think we're in the
wrong place now we're in the vote aren't
we right okay
motion is is as per the um
as per the report with the addition of
um reference to jlp policy spo3 I think
councilman crawl wants to say something
one moment cancel
I I just I mean I think we need to go to
the vote on this but I do find it rather
worrying that um
application
um listening to the applicants who were
under the impression two weeks ago that
this application was getting an approval
The Joint local plan and then the
neighborhood plan of coming to play
which has turned that on its head
and the and quite honestly the
information in the neighborhood plan
which is not actually voted for and
could get turned down is basically
deciding this this vote I think it's I I
think
the the advice or the officer's
recommendation is flawed
um on the basis of that because this is
not a document that has been adopted it
could be turned down at referendum by
the council and we've seen clearly that
there is an alternative view in Holbrook
because we've got a supporter of that
plan I do think it's very dangerous and
I as you know as I second councilor
Busby's proposed to defer it I think we
are
on very thin ground here and I think if
it went to an appeal
I think they'd probably get it so
because I think it's not a good decision
if we go with the officer recommendation
thank you councilor Barrett I would
remind you that we have a procedure now
of how we take things on the basis of
them emerging as for the jlp and the
neighborhood plan
comes the bear he wants to ask uh yes I
just want to ask the question
um the recommendation on page 44 when
the slide was up uh slide 25 that said
recommend addition for refusal was
specific on a a particular issue uh I'm
assuming
that was housingly
um I'm assuming that the page 44 this is
all the ingredients to that but you're
saying reasons here I was under the
impression there was just one Pacific
Reason Not reasons
and I think it is important because if
these people have to go to appeal they
need to know whether they appear on all
these reasonings that you've got in the
um page 44 or on this specific could you
put slide 25 perhaps yeah and we can
save time it's it's what's in the red
it's at the bottom of the commission
report that is the recommendation I
think think that was an attempt to
having a summary of what the points were
but they all went it into
that one long paragraph at the bottom of
the commission report on page I hear
what you're saying but I did ask the
question right at the beginning on slide
25 what was the Pacific reason did you
put that up again uh the the that's my
argument is that if this is refused
which it may be or may not be
um the applicant needs to know what
they've got to argue on and Page 44
showed lots of reasons
and it was there thank you thank you
yeah it's a council of beer local I
don't let me put my glasses on because
that might help me that one
um local identified need
Pacific
please yeah councilor if I may the
presentation is a summary of all the
details contained in the
report that is
the recommendation based in the report
and a decision notice will be issued
which will give the full details of the
reason for referral refusal if if that
is the way it goes so this supports the
report but all of this the actual what
we're voting on is contained in the
report and not the presentation
yes so this is the reason for refusal
thank you councilor hold
yeah would the proposer and second to
consider an amendment in that um this
particular item is refused pureed on
cs11 due to the fact that
npo1 and hnp02 that's referred to in the
office of refusal has been clearly
um the Waters of it have been muddied in
my opinion I think of several members
opinions and that I don't really see
that it would be useful to have those in
there if there are concerns about
Clarity of those policies because we're
questioning the evidence and also the
numbers involved
and I just feel that it would be easier
possibly to have them removed
do you
know
no
so we go to the boat the inspectors
looked at the report and he's made his
recommendations and
the these assumptions are based on that
okay we will go thank you you agree as a
second I'm just going to say I agree and
Charlie we support hnp01 and hnpo2 and I
see no reason to weaken the reason for
refusal okay we will go to the vote
well can I just say that
the problem I face is that
um
I don't I don't agree with refusal I
don't agree with making the decision
because I feel that the information
isn't there therefore
I can't vote for
the application because
I'm still not sure of the information
therefore the only alternative for me is
to abstain and I'm will abstain because
the information isn't available to make
the right decision in my view
can do what they like obviously
including abstaining but the a
resolution is a resolution to do what it
says which in this case would be to
refuse it's
assume that means we do the opposite
the opposite of refusal isn't
necessarily acceptance it may be
something else
thank you so so chair um but those are
the words I mean I suppose we I suppose
we should just brief election CS2 as
well as that's our main special policy
um Plus
the uh jlp policies
that's the only amendment I suggest you
want
could the officer just expand a little
bit
simply because it's not within a built
up area boundary so that's the beginning
of our local policy I mean CS2 is
law but it's it's outside the settlement
limits so we might as well just include
that as well I think I think it's
superseded by the more recent
neighborhood plan that I can accept well
as you know where we're juggling okay
you don't think this weakens the reason
for refusal in any way since CS2 itself
has been challenged in part
it's just at the beginning point of how
we have you know we've allocate this
it's outside that therefore and then we
go into the real nuts and bolts of the
arguments which are cs11 jlp based so
yes 11 as a place of spo3 yeah okay are
you happy for that John
happy with that thank you
thank you
okay
the vote set up we will now move to the
vote thank you thank you chair members
that vote is in progress for you uh
Council of Mayor can I take a vote
against
the roof Resort thank you
thank you chair so that's
six votes four refusal and four votes
against refusal that application is
refused notifications refused thank you
if I say 10
okay everyone please let's make a start
this is planning application DC 2201 605
Hill Farm Barnes Hill Farm old London
Road
um
Council Busby are you staying on the
committee or stepping down to be a ward
member
that's down the committee Elementary
's controversial it's whether it's you
feel comfortable that you're not so I
just wanted to get that in to set the
ground rules oh thank you
uh
I know his wife's not been too well
I know remember his family's not been
too well
foreign
I will now invite the case officer
Elizabeth flood to introduce the
application committee Elizabeth thank
you
so this is an application for outline
planning permission uh with access to be
considered at this point for demolition
of existing redundant farm buildings an
eviction of up to 19 dwellings with a
new access off the malverns
um as with the previous application
um it's set out in your late papers the
cop.com washbrook neighborhood plan
has now got some weight less weight than
the Holbrook one because this has just
got to
um reg 14 but it has some weight
um you may remember that the cop dock
and washbrook neighborhood plan failed
at referendum this is a new version so
they've started again
um and so this is a stage reg 14 stage
the jlp also has some weight
particularly in this in this case policy
spo3 and the policies within the
neighborhood plan would
not support the development because it's
outside the settlement boundary however
in this case under the existing plan the
local plan we consider it is generally
compliant with cs11 and compliant with
CS2 in relation to the X um the
um
considerations and also
um the um and also the material
considerations outside of the policies
would in this case support the
application it's quite rare that we get
them that are like this where we say
there are other material considerations
that have such weight that we could
maybe put our policies aside but in this
case we consider that there is and we'll
explain about that in the in the
in the report in the
so
sight
um
you can see that um it's basically split
split into two parts there's the field
and
so
this part is a small agricultural field
and then above it is the buildings and
the um and sort of this is the derelict
area with the burnt out buildings The
Farmhouse and the overgrown land and
then this part is development you can
see the maldons down here this is Old
London Road or London Road it's these
big sort of interchangeable what it's
called goes up here and then
um it's a gate there and then it's all
pedestrian and you'll remember this
because we went to the site visit you go
under here and then you get into coptock
interchange into the park and ride and
Tesco and so on
um
and the built off our area boundary is
actually here down here and so all this
is currently outside the built up area
boundary but within the new copdock and
washbrook neighborhood plan this area
would have us would have assessment
boundary
so again you can see the application
site here you can see the existing
buildings
and you'll notice that the applicant
which is Suffolk County Council own this
field as well so they own a wider part
of the land
constraints
um so key constraints are built up area
boundary which is down here you can see
the flood zone so this would sort of
prevent any development within adjacent
to the settlement boundary in this case
which is why the malverns were developed
here originally as a royal exception
site
um
you can also
um see that it's all within a special
landscape area
and what it doesn't show on here but it
will show in another constraint another
map is that there are four TPO trees on
or close to the site
so here this shows this is the
parameters plan so this would be a plan
that if you were to support the
development we would include this as one
of the plans and this would
show where development wouldn't be
acceptable so you can see the four TPO
trees with their root protection zone so
this would prevent any Development
coming forward on those areas and it
also shows the area that is of risk of
surface water flooding and again this
parameters plan would would not support
any development on that area
you can also see the access onto the
malverns
this is an indicative layout only so
this is all indicative apart from the
access so you can see that the access
would be up here from the malverns and
then you'd have your 19 dwellings set
out here
the attenuation Basin would be located
in this area which is the lowest area of
land the land slopes down this way
and this way you can see the flood zone
which no development would happen in you
can see that this tree is protected as
in within public open space again
there's a small area public open space
here to protect this tree and then this
tree would be kept within the would oh
it's sort of on the boundary so it would
come into the um The Gardens of these
two properties but they've got quite big
plots
so it's it's a lot of this design has
been designed around keep protecting
those trees and ensuring that they
wouldn't have pressure to fail them in
the future
this
this area you can see that the
Landscaping would retain along London
Road and along the malverns as much as
possible and some additional Landscaping
at the rear and at the side
again as you can as a sloping slide so
you can see on the indicative site
section that there would need to be some
infill and some digging
and we'd probably look at putting a
levels condition on any reserved matters
and again it doesn't show up on this
section but there would need to be some
Works to get the access in
so this is the key component of this
application so by
stopping by putting the access here it
means that we can stop the access up
here the existing access from into the
hill farm barns which means that this
part of the road can be stopped up from
it for Rick from regular traffic so at
the there would be two bollards here and
two bollards here and some building out
here and then we would look
um it's not quite been clarified what
can be done but there would be we would
look to get some signage here so this
would then become two-way this part of
the carriage rate only only accesses one
dwelling white cottage in this location
um but we can't close this up because
these residents need to be able to
access their garage and parking areas so
this would become two-way we're hoping
that we can get some signage up to say
access to white cottage only
um but it wouldn't prevent other
vehicles
um using it but it would hopefully
dissuade other vehicles from using it
and then we'd be looking at some
bollards at the top to stop people
driving all the way around
so at the moment there are footways
within washbrook and in cop dock and
they sort of finish here so people in
order to get to the the rest of the
pedestrian walkway which is up here they
have to walk along the road and it is
lightly trafficked but it's it's
non-redicted so in fairy cars could go
at 60 mile an hour up here and go round
um so it is considered that this is a
a really good proposal in terms of the
sustainability of the village because it
will encourage more people to walk along
here and then this gets you into Tesco
to the bus stops and so on so it's it's
it's really good for the sustainability
of the village
so here are the some photos you probably
remember this from site but the access
would be just up here just once you get
into the malverns like I say the there
would have to be some
um profiling of the access and some of
this um
landscape would be lost
um this is the existing foot way into uh
sorry existing vehicular access into the
um the site so this will become a
pedestrian and cycle access and then the
dwellings would be here this is a
category B tray which on the indicative
layout is shown to be removed but we
would look at Reserve matters about
whether that could be retained
again this is looking back so that's the
access onto London Road these are the
two TPO trade this is the other tree
um
and this is within the site again you
can see the two TPO trees you can see
that there's quite a lot of fly tipping
and so on at the moment it's a bit of a
mess
that's the existing dwelling that would
be removed there are it is used by bats
a little bit so they would require a bat
license before they demolish the
building but ecology haven't
them I'm concerned provided they get
their bat license
again these are some more of the built a
burnt out buildings burnt out cars
this is looking back onto the site so
you can see the burnt out buildings this
would be sort of the end
of the site here
this is the other part of the site so
the field so the malverns you can just
see it down there and these are the
other two TPO trees
so this would be developed for housing
okay again this is looking into the sort
of agricultural field part of the site
you can see the Landscaping there for
the malverns some of that on this end
would be lost to get the access up but
the rest would be retained and that's
quite important because these these
houses are sort of going to be above
above the ones in the malverns
again similar view you can see the um
that the farm house and these pine trees
would be removed
and this just gives you an idea of um
the sort of character around so that's
the morvens
um and this is the slope and this is the
Landscaping that would be retained again
this is looking down from the site down
to the Malvern so you can see there will
be quite a a difference in levels but
they are physically separated
okay and these are showing you what
would um happen on London Road so this
would be this is the access to the
malverns this would be where it would be
built out and the bollards would be put
on so all this would then become a
pedestrian and Cycle Way
again this is looking at it from white
cottage so this is white cottage
this would become two-way
and the bollards would be on this side
and then this is right at the end so
that's the access so the other bollards
would just be put up here
and it's hope that we can get some
Landscaping of this Verge as well so
some trees planted ideally
and this shows
um
just the last bit which is the
um the entrance into the rest of the
pedestrian bit that of the road
and finally this is a picture from Swan
Hill so it is a special landscape area
but the only place the development will
be really visible from is this this
going down this road
um and you can just see the malverns
there so what the applicant has agreed
is that they will put a hedge this is
all in their ownership it's all Suffolk
County councils so they will put a hedge
with some trees on this corner here and
that will help filter the views of the
development which would be sort of here
and it will also help to filter the
existing views of the morphins
so the recommendation is as set out in
your report is one of approval
um
due to either the material
considerations and
um CS2 in terms of exceptional
circumstances thank you
thank you Elizabeth
I'm waiting for the light to come up
soon
Mr chairman I think I don't know if I
need to declare an interest that I'm a
member of Suffolk County Council and I'm
Suffolk County council's planning
committee but I've never discussed this
site with any of my colleagues there or
what have you that I thought I ought to
just point that out to you I don't know
what the legal situation is I don't
think that compromises councilor Beer's
position I've been on the site
inspection with babe thank you
thank you chair
Elizabeth when we did the site
inspection visit
when we were in the mornings there was a
lot of water coming down from that site
probably we chose a bad day but there
was a lot of what have we got enough in
place to prevent that
within the um the conditions so we would
look to put on a such condition for the
surface water within the site so that
would that would prevent that should
deal with the drainage within the site
and then in terms of the access road we
would look to put in a drain or
something at the bottom of the access
road to stop it raining into
um into into the mold and
thank you
Crow
Elizabeth uh thanks for that it's um
about the access
um at the top of the former
world of proposals with bollards and
everything else allow uh retention of
the current cycle access under the a12
and into the sort of Ipswich network of
cycle routes
yes so the bollards are only there to
prevent Vehicles so they will be wide
enough that Cycles can get through and
then it will provide a cycle because
eventually there is the hope that or it
will all be cycle way all the way from
Capel or along the road to cop dock so
this will be the first 80 meters of that
cycle you kept saying pedestrian I want
you to establish that it is actually
cycle access and I think it's also part
of the designated scheme for our own
cycle strategy within suffolk's
framework yeah it will be cycle and
pedestrian they won't be segregated in
any way because the width of the road is
considered wide enough that there
shouldn't be any shared use thanks
councilman
thank you yes that's a quick question
concerning uh the size of the site 19
homes looking at the visual
presentations Etc compared to the
malverns it seems like extremely dense
housing stuck on the outside of that
area so what is the size of the Hat what
is the density of housing on the site
I don't know what the density is I think
the malverns is 18 or 20 dwellings so
it's a similar size but the malverns
does include some Flats so although it
looks less dense it is a similar number
of actual dwellings
trying to hold
yep um obviously this is an outline and
one of the major things we have to look
at is access and I'm a little bit
concerned that we haven't got detail
um officers presentation has included
this might happen that might happen on
the old section of the a12
um
it's all to do with the access and of
the objections raised online certainly
all the objections were to do with the
roads and the access points and the
traffic the bollard's not preventing
motorbikes Etc using that particular
section
um so I'm a little bit disappointed we
haven't got more detail
an accuracy in what is proposed it's
being left again for us not to be able
to vote on anything other than purely
access to the site
the road alterations I think a key to
this certainly for locals by the sound
of it and yet we haven't got the detail
so I'm a little bit concerned about that
another thing I'd like to raise is the
four trees from nature
yep
we can get that answer first so
Highway improvements as shown on the
plan so basically the two sets of
bollards and the building out to to
those bollards is would be confirmed and
would be as part of a condition they had
to do those the two things that haven't
yet been
clarified is what signage can be put up
in in terms of
um access signage to
um to the
white cottage so whether we can ask for
a sign that says access only to white
cottage and what if any
Landscaping would happen on those Verge
so the fundamental issue of shutting
that road to Vehicles would be part of
this application so it would include a
condition but there are two question
marks at the moment one on signage and
one on Landscaping
yeah it was certainly access to white
cottage which was one in particular I
was interested in because we just don't
seem to have Clarity on that the other
thing was the four trees can we
guarantee their protection
as in we have schemes on outline but
when detail comes in the plans change
and then suddenly gone so can we at this
stage guarantee them or is it our
aspiration to keep them those are all
TPO trees so they are protected and as
long as they remain healthy they will be
protected but what we would if you were
to approve this application we would
include that parameters plan that shows
the retention of the two the four trees
and their root protection zones so
whatever came in could not develop on
those sites and again the flood area
no
thank you Elizabeth
we'll move on to
the only public speaker we have is
Michael colder you're speaking as the
agent you have three minutes to address
the committee
good morning I'm from phase two planning
planning the corporate property division
of Suffolk County Council
proposals before you are the results of
extensive consultation and guidance from
your officers developed over the last
two years and considered extensively by
all relevant consultees
we hope that you'll take comfort in your
officer's recommendation for approval
which is supported by no objections from
any statutory consultees and is
supported by the parish council
one of the many benefits of this
proposal is that it will promote
sustainable travel and improve highway
safety through measures that will
prioritize safe pedestrian and cycle
access between the Villages of copdock
and washbrook and the facilities at The
coptock Interchange which are within 500
meters of the site
a scheme for Highway off-site works is
submitted with the application it's
available on the website and for your
decision today
the local transport enhancements will
provide residents that wish to access
key services with a genuine choice of
transport options other than using the
car because it will be quicker to walk
and cycle to these facilities than drive
such initiatives are consistent with the
objective of the mppf to maximize
sustainable Transport Solutions in new
development
these measures will also benefit
existing residents of copdock and
washbrook and is considered to be a
significant local benefit from this
proposal we therefore agree with your
officers that this benefit provides
exceptional circumstances required by
the adopted local plan
your officers have also confirmed that
there is a proven local need for housing
in the village and in the absence of a
neighborhood plan and delays with the
adoption of a new local plan there are
no current allocations to provide this
need however is confirmed by officers
this site is considered an appropriate
location to meet these unmet local
housing needs
again we agree with officers that
meeting these local needs supports
approval of this application
in addition the proposals will provide
six new affordable homes alongside a
contribution again providing much needed
affordable housing for those with the
greatest need
neighboring residents have acknowledged
that the proposal will result in local
transport improvements but some have
expressed their desire for further
measures the applicant has gone as far
as is reasonably proportionate to the
development to address existing
conditions and it shall be for the
highway authority to investigate the
neighbor's requests as part of a broader
review outside the scope of this
application
the parish council recognizes that there
are local benefits such as enhancing a
site resembling dereliction and
providing a use that will remove ongoing
anti-social behavior and fly tipping
from the sites the SE matters are a
local concern
there are therefore a number of clear
benefits from this proposal and we
support your officer's conclusion that
any impacts are minor and do not
outweigh those clear benefits
with planning conditions and completion
of a section 106 agreement officers
support this proposal and we therefore
urge you to follow your officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you very much are any questions
for the agent
thank you just a quick question I'm sure
as rep you're representing the County
Council Who are the
local highways Authority a labor bopsy
beating some consultation with highways
National Highway sorry they keep
changing their name I forget what
they're called this week
um National highways over the
improvements of the mill interchange
which will obviously come very close to
this site and will probably impact upon
it have those been taken into
consideration with your proposals or are
you waiting until you've got permission
and then you'll try and sort out the
problems afterwards
let's say they have been considered um I
think within the officers report it
shows you that the national highways
were a console t on this application uh
to the authority as well so yeah there
has been involvement they have made
comments to the application and it's
been brought into account in the
decision making
any more questions
draw your attention to what I said to
the officer actually about the highways
concerns um re whites Cottage and the
access to it and obviously there's been
some comments in the objections about
um
youngsters using it for Gatherings and
hgv parkings and if you're going to
restrict half of the road and block it
off aren't we just encouraging that to
be transferred right in front of White's
cottage instead of necessarily the
opposite side so would you consider
going forward some restrictions whether
it be HIV restrictions or other ways of
controlling what vehicular access can go
to and Beyond white cottage because I
think that that is a bit of an issue in
the it's a known problem at the moment
by the sounds of it
it's a Once opportunity to make sure if
this development gets approval you could
control and negate what is happening
there now and not re occur right in
front of a landowner's property
yeah thank you so um
there are a number of measures already
proposed there's a there's a a proposed
off-site London Road cycle scheme plan
as part of this application that you
might have seen it's been produced by
the highway consultants and on that
there's a number of measures showing
signage and Road markings that are
proposed outside of the property you're
referring to and that's a preliminary
step we think in terms of measures that
can be taken and of course we're quite
restricted in terms of what's fair and
proportionate and meets the seal
regulations that we can do with this
application so we've tried to match that
with optimizing what we can do and I
think if this was to go forward it then
certainly continues that discussion for
that broader review that continues to
take place and there are opportunities
outside of this application for traffic
regulation orders to put signage up make
make changes to that side of the highway
actually that helps thank you
thank you thank you
Council Busby
I guess I know what the answer is going
to be before I ask you but so why ask it
um for this same subject really in terms
of the amendments to the
extent this development shouldn't
necessarily pay to to solve all of the
yields of that particular area however
it could go a long way to contribute to
solving many of them
it's difficult to tell at this point
What's going to work and what's not
going to work
um
and I think the residents would accept
that
seems okay so far but what happens if it
doesn't work or it causes more problems
could there be a fund put aside
fifty thousand quid say
four highways to work with the residents
to resolve issues that arise in the
future rather than try and solve them
all at this point in time
you said you knew my answer so um but so
the answer is very similar to the first
in in the sense that I can see that I
can see the Practical advantages of that
I think that the local planning
Authority and the applicant is quite
constrained by working Within These seal
regulations around not going too far
beyond
what is considered to be offsetting your
your own impacts and not trying to
address pre-existing conditions that are
not of your making so there is this
balance that we're trying to to get the
right side of our way through but um how
that then plays out is that going
forward as the highway Authority there
are those other measures and funds
available to them to certainly address
existing or subsequent um
issues so I think that should something
occur or should should things outside
his application continue There are other
means and measures for the higher
authority to deal with that outside of
this application
thank you I hear what you say yeah
with all due respect to highways
we know it's like if I squeeze blood out
of a stone to get money to do changes if
we could look at slide eight I could
just explain something which
isn't covered at the moment
but could be an issue in the future
which is a result of this
um
make it slide
eight up
it's always at the opposite end to where
you've got it
okay
um
at the moment you see at the for those
that don't know the area the the road on
the bottom left Chapel Lane
is where most of the traffic goes it
comes down old London Road
and then turns left at the bottom and
then goes up swell as well as Hill
equally in the reverse it comes down
swallows Hill a long Chapel Lane and
then no not that one that's the Marvin's
the bottom one and it turns right
there but it comes in theory it's
supposed to give way in theory in
practice nobody does they come straight
out of there because
there's no traffic on the old London
Road why should there be and turn
straight up the road now
we've already got the development at the
it's called the Marvin's by the way
Marvin's the Marvin's which has got a
certain number of houses and you've got
another development here that will
increase the number of
vehicles that will come down old London
Road and go straight up
and they could re meet traffic that
think they've got the right-of-way
coming out of that turning now highways
have said there's no need for a sign a
stop sign on either of those
now that's their call at the moment it
might be that after we've had two or
three serious accidents they've changed
the mind will there be the money for it
that's the kind of change I think we
ought to put money aside for
uh to see whether the changes occur
is that the question you're asking well
that's yes well can we get an answer to
that then you can answer your next one
so I don't have the authority right here
right now to make any commitments to
towards doing anything beyond what's
currently in the application
um
and of course for the very reasons
you've said that it's not been
identified
as a requirement for us to do those
things again I totally accept the
practicality of the points that you're
making
certainly there is a recommendation for
a section 106.
obligation to be entered into by the
applicant if planning permission is
granted and there are a number of
planning conditions that's been
recommended by the highway Authority
so
um
there is of course
an opportunity for this committee
to vote on a recommendation to include
something within those obligations that
aren't currently written in the report
but as I say I don't have the authority
to
um
accept anything beyond the report
because that again brings us back to
what the applicant's been asked to do
can I ask that chat since this is a this
is a recommendation on access and
outline planning
access to me implies
a little bit through the Marvin's it
doesn't include all of the necessary
other changes that we're talking about
to highways will that be part of the
full application and will we have a
chance therefore to
put in conditions at that point
so if I can come in
it would be a condition so that drawing
of slide eight would be one of the
conditions on this outline application
so we would put a condition on that
uh you know I were prior to development
or at some point those those Works would
have to be done we would put it we'd
have to put it on this outline not on
the reserve matters because it is a
fundamental part of this application so
we wouldn't be looking at those changes
again at Reserve matters they don't
require planning permission because
their works are the highway but they
need to be included in as a condition of
this application because that's the only
reason why we would support this
application
in that case chair can I ask also that
at the moment there is a de-restricted
road speed sign
at the bottom
if you go back to slide eight sorry
you see the Red Dot at the bottom of
that slide yeah you just moved it
there there is a de-restriction speed
sign so once you get over that Crossing
you can Theory do 60 miles an hour
bearing in mind you've only got about 30
or 40 yards to do it it doesn't seem to
have any sense at all to keep it as a
60mph
can that be sliced off on the left for
being 40 which is the rest of the speed
limit I sorry I've spoken to Highway
Authority about this and they have
suggested I mean a tro does cost about
10 000 pounds that's what we usually ask
for as a contribution they have say
stead they have spoken to their tro
officer and they don't believe it is
necessary for that small area what they
have asked for as part of this
application is they have confirmed that
the Melvins I'll say right is should in
theory be a 30 mile an hour Zone but
there is no signage so what they have
asked as part of this application is 30
mile an hour signs here that wouldn't
require the entrance to the Marvins so
that and that wouldn't require a tro and
then that would cover both the new
development and the Marvin's
but that still leaves a 60 mold on our
side at the bottom of the road which
means that you're doing 60 for 20 for 20
yards I mean look it does not cost ten
thousand pounds for a tin of black paint
or a chainsaw
I thank you
supposed to be foreign
[Music]
I believe the answer is that
they they would need to do a tro to get
a change in the 60 is that correct
so you're stuck with it
councilor Hinton
sorry this is not a question for the
applicant uh are we finished with the
applicant now or not
okay
Mr chairman if I could just make a make
a point here if you look at page 62
recommendations
brackets two the last but one bullet
point as recommended by Highway
Authority including off-site
improvements to London Road and 30 mile
an hour signage for the Malvern
Marvin's Marvin's Melbourne for another
to those to those Hills in the west
country
um
can't we put something in there which
requires them
handicants are going to make money out
of this site if it cost them ten
thousand pounds for tro so it comes off
their bottom line for the development
let's make sure that it is safe for
people to use when they start work on
the cop talk Mill interchange
sometime in about 20 40 I think is
probably the latest estimate the traffic
down the old London Road and going up
around there is going to increase
exponentially so it's going to become a
real safety hazard and if it's just the
only opportunity we've got to put some
sort of restriction on there or sudden
sort of control on there then let's do
it let's put it on there
I asked him Elizabeth you will see
whether this is
that Mark please
so are you asking for Works which The
Authority itself has said that's not
been asked but has not asked to be done
in their consultation response
yes because we think they're taking the
shortcut cheap way out okay
um
I mean in answer your question
theoretically yes you can ask for that I
don't know whether he wants to chip in
here
um
you okay yeah yeah yes you can ask for
it but you have to justify it really
who are the people that we are asking to
do this so basically we're asking them
to be judged and jury on their own
decisions so
um
yes
what a different hats are being worn yes
now I appreciate the different
difficulty I mean I'm not sure he get
who gets ten thousand pounds for a tro
whether it pays for lawyers or whether
it pays for the highway Authority but I
mean I think we want to have some
condition in there regarding all these
General points and I think the officers
already suggested that the discussions
have taken place on that
um
is it possible to include the condition
that the the thoughts of the meeting
such as councilor Busby has presented
and councilor Hinton and that there are
concerns about this speed limit to
things and but I'm very much aware that
the people we're asking to carry the
workout and make the decision
are the people that we're putting the
condition on and it's a very peculiar
situation but I think we've got to at
least put that condition in and would
that in officers opinions cover the
circumstances the um members have been
described I think if you're asking for
that we'd probably go to put in the 106
as his tro rather than the condition
yeah if members feel it's necessary to
make the scheme safe in Highway terms
obviously the highway Authority itself
hasn't said that
we're the local planning Authority and
we can make conditions regarding
sections we can as long as they're
reasonable well I think they are
reasonable and I think the the mood of
the committee is probably going to be
that they are
let's establish it with most people be
in favor of that
I won't bother to take it to your folks
at this stage I don't think we're going
to resolve it today yeah can I just
clarify that that so you're talking
about short stretch of road which uh
still have a 60 mile an hour sign on it
you've got to have a 30 miles is that is
that the sign that you're talking about
I think that would be a simple summary
wouldn't it
yeah I think Mr chairman I think it also
needs some Road markings to show who's
got priority one thing at a time one
thing at a time please gentlemen so
number one we are talking about you want
tro
to change the speed limit or what you
you want the speed limit changed however
yes just the sign removed and some
signage we're actually just taking a
sign yeah let's let's settle the one
thing first okay we'll settle that then
you're saying you want signage on that
Junction
to improve the road safety there yep so
we have two matters
is that clearance with what that means
to you
to you yeah Elizabeth sorry
he's being asked that I think what you
could do is ask as part of the 106 for a
contribution towards the tro which would
cover speed limits and potential other
traffic improvements
has to be said and I think it's fully
unlikely in this but the tros can be
aren't guaranteed so people can you know
object and these objections can behold
and that would that would include chair
um the um whether the traffic flows are
likely to meet as is described at that
Junction because it is it is a
right-hand term and of course not only
is it a right hand turn coming one way
or left turn the other way but if it's
the right hand turn you have to cross a
line of traffic where the road used to
go and then cross to the other
carriageway on the opposite side because
the road is split right down the middle
yeah and if that makes it even more
difficult I'd suggest
does it necessarily have to have the
words t-ro in Euros 106 condition
or was it just traffic Improvement for
this
for the so and that
and that those costs to be covered by
the applicant the applicant isn't
usually the highway Authority but I
think it might be the easiest thing to
ask for that contribution so check me
again we put slide eight back up again
because I just want to explain Elizabeth
you said that there's a proposal to put
a 30 mile an hour sign at the entrance
to the Marvin's
there well that's going to require a tro
anyway
because at the moment that's 60 miles an
hour the Marvin's itself is
it's got a speed
it hasn't got a speed limit sign but
the highway Authority have told me is
because it is got no other signs and
because it's got Street lamps strictly
it is 30 but it's just not very clear so
they can put up a a 30 mile an hour
speed limit sign at the entrance to this
just to make it clearer but but that
wouldn't need a tro because it is
technically 30 but this area is not as
deep restricted it's not 30. so if you
wanted to have this area at 30 miles an
hour or any of this or 40 or whatever
you were proposing that would require
tro because it would legally need to
change that speed limit
so there we have it folks we're going to
put go to all the trouble and cost of
putting a 30 mile an hour sign up to the
entrance of a road where nobody ever
does more than 20 miles an hour anyway
yet we can't be bothered to put the sign
up for a piece of road they where
they're currently allowed to do 60. I
mean that's that's
Bonkers isn't it but
but except the I think what Alistair
says I think we should put something in
there to
just clarify the tro obviously um I
think one of the members already said
this we can't it's not given there's a
public consultation process it could be
a third party objects and holds that up
so I think any resolution there has to
be an open end to it so that we can do
something else just determined they can
take up to two years to get them they
have to consult with all the residents
there
um but there is a procedure and the
likelihood is that it would get through
eventually
okay but what the planning officer is
asking for is something a bit open-ended
so it if it doesn't happen first time
around it doesn't close so we carry on
with the three and as it's the county
itself
there might be more reason to settle for
the local County Council of that area
can actually back this and that will get
through a lot quicker
do you know who the county councilor is
yeah it's Chris Hudson
okay thank you
are we happy with that
um a 106
condition
we can start with that but we can't
guarantee the tro
op yeah so we'll have to I don't know if
we can come back if we can't get the tro
we can you can delegate us to sort it
out what you want to do
yes yeah and we'll add that to the
motion okay
I mean if the tro doesn't go through
then we okay we can't then make it 30
miles an hour we just don't have control
to do that let's ask for it let's see
yep okay
okay try we're very trying
thank you Mark
trying to get
other
assistance check in that case can I move
that we go to the vote and I propose
that we accept the officer's
recommendations okay we have a second
ring cancer beer councilor Hulk do you
wanted to make a comment before we I
just want to add hgv an them get a sign
up that's mentioned in the papers it's
been mentioned by objectors if we're
going to do this why not ban those hgvs
for the given or given them the
opportunity to depart Beyond
that section of road because at the
moment they do so it would be just as
easy to tag that on as well ban hgvs
from going Beyond there so they don't go
down there and park up overnight and
cause a disturbance and also I do think
it's very unfortunate you are the
applicant but hey it's Suffolk County
Council we should all get on and provide
what residents want and there are real
concerns about this for residents
so can we
add that part of this s106
yes
I mean it's getting quite adventurous
chair
what's being asked for it
they were here earlier yeah I I have
some nerves about that actually about
the uh
TVs it's distinctive
Mr chairman
can I help on that I'm at the moment
looking at some
um fan and some lorries in a certain
area which I won't comment because I
mustn't but um the local County
councilor can take that up for you and I
would have thought that um this
um removal of lorries or restrictions or
some times where you cannot park for any
level for time they have to be enforced
is the right course of action to go so I
think you need to involve the local
County councilor there but there's no
reason why you can't mention it through
the oral planning as our plan and
officers to the local County Council and
asked him to look into it for you
so that's a request to have a
conversation rather than anything that
would be in the decision yeah
also yeah I've been on this nearly two
years but we are seeing some lies at the
end of the tunnel
so you're happy
right so I have exposure in the second
though
um can I
please have you ring that yes it's as
per the um Commission report chair with
the addition of reference to jlp
policies such as they are relevant to a
certain extent
um and also to add into the
recommendation of the 106 and 106 to
include reference to a tro or or such
other measures as may be deliverable
um
and for officers as an informative
officer to discuss with the County
Council about
um
jcv is not being allowed down there
so that's what we're voting on
please go to your book
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's Carrie thank you
thank you
flipping boats four and that is the end
of the meeting our next meeting is
scheduled for the 5th of April in the
Elizabeth Frink room
um we also have one scheduled for
Fortnight after that
um at this moment in time those are
still both on the cards the one that was
in for the fourth uh for the third of
May 3rd of May the day before the
election has been postponed
close the meeting thank you